oui
jello comme on dit chez nous elles
tiennent ce soir je vais vous parler de
mobile money mobile money qu'est ce que
c'est mobile money mais on français
mobile money c'est argent mobile est ce
que c'est une nouvelle monnaie est ce
que c'est le cfa2 demain où le dollar ou
le euros non mobile money n'est pas une
monnaie c'est pas une nouvelle monnaie
mobile money n'est pas le dollar le cfa2
demain comment ça fonctionne
le mobile money le mauvais lé money ces
deux mondes
c'est l'argent virtuel d'un côté et
l'argent le cash on liquide ou à la
banque
de l'autre côté quand vous faites une
transaction au mobile money il ya
toujours les deux qui se font en même
temps en temps réel au monde virtuel et
au monde réel de l'autre côté fait par
exemple un cash in m'appelle un cachet
vous avez vingt mille cfa et vous voulez
le déposer votre compte mon mobile money
qu'est-ce qui se passe vous allez faire
un marchand qui va recevoir vos vingt
mille cfa et il va vous transférez vingt
mille cfa en monnaie mobile money
virtuel et en même temps son compte à
lui où il ya aussi les vingt mille cfa à
la banque prête des beats et à ce moment
là il a vingt mille cfa dans sa poche
le vin me cfa que vous lui avez donné et
sur son compte virtuel si au début il
avait cent mille il lui reste quatre
vingt mille alors nous sommes pas
créateur de l'argent nous inventons pas
une nouvelle monnaie
non nous faisons juste des transactions
les transactions dans un monde virtuel
qui en même temps est compensée par les
mêmes transactions au niveau du cash au
niveau du bang
alors pourquoi en très peu de temps sur
tous dans notre continent l'afrique
le mobile money a connu un tel succès
pour parler de succès de l'un je me
permets même si à peut-être beaucoup de
banquiers dans la salle de parler de
l'échec ou un petit échec des autres et
les autres c'est les banques
oui une des raisons du succès de
nouvelles monnaies c'est aussi l'échec
un peu des banques
pourquoi aujourd'hui il ya 5 ou 10% de
la population en côte d'ivoire façon
générale en afrique qui ont un compte en
banque
par contre il ya presque cent pour cent
de la population qui est un téléphone
mobile
pourquoi les banques n'ont pas réussi à
faire ce que les opérateurs de
téléphonie sont en train de faire dans
ce monde de mauvaise monnaie vous savez
que la plus grande banque en côte
d'ivoire je vais pas nommer le nom à 120
agences 120 en 50 ans d'existence
maintenant si vous voulez faire une
transaction chez eux depuis hier à midi
jusqu'à mardi matin
ce ne sera pas possible parce que c'est
dimanche c'est pentecôte
ça ouvre mardi à 9 heures
par contre si vous voulez faire une
transaction mobile money je peut vous
amener à le point le plus proche se sera
pas 500 m je vous garantis même
maintenant
dimanche après midi à 16h30 vous allez
trouver un marchand mobile money qui va
faire votre transaction
nous en avons aujourd'hui 5000 en côte
d'ivoire en trois ans 120 agences en 50
ans il doit vivre sur le rythme des
horreurs ou des horaires pardon c'est
parfois aussi des horreurs mobile money
n'a pas ce problème parce que nous ce
nous nous sommes réinventer à travers
d'une expérience dans la téléphonie
mobile comme maîtrise bien ses de la
distribution à tout moment donné par
tous abidjan l'intérieur du pays presque
24 heures sur 24
vous pouvez acheter du crédit et c'est
ce même modèle que nous avons reproduit
au niveau de mobile money avec nos
marchands c'est la simplicité et la
disponibilité du service qui a fait le
succès qu'il est aujourd'hui mais c'est
pas seul la seule raison pour ouvrir un
compte en banque il ya jusqu'à
maintenant encore des pays qui vous
demande pas uniquement une facture
d'électricité mais aussi une facture de
téléphone fixe qui aujourd'hui a encore
un téléphone fixe
si vous ne m'avez pas je suis désolé
vous pouvez pas ouvrir un compte en
banque
par contre mobile money
vous faites identifier correctement
selon les règles du jeu une pièce
d'identité
on prend la photocopie aux notes qui
vous êtes et dans les cinq minutes qui
suivent vous pouvez commencer à entrer
dans le monde des finances
parce que c'est ça mobile money c'est la
démocratisation de l'accès aux services
financiers qui pendant des années et des
années
on était le privilège presque presque le
le l'exclusivité d'une petite élite qui
aujourd'hui s'ouvre à tout le monde et
les transactions les transactions sont
très simples et beaucoup de transactions
dans une société comme la nôtre sont des
transactions de faible valeur
5 10000 20000 mais beaucoup de
transactions dans une société où
beaucoup de gens vis sur un revenu
journalier
malheureusement aujourd'hui très peu de
gens ont réellement un revenu mensuel
avec un virement d'un salaire mensuel
il ya beaucoup plus de gens qui ont un
revenu hebdomadaire ou parfois même
journalier alors il ya beaucoup de
transactions de cash mille francs 2000
francs 5000 francs et beaucoup de
transactions et le mobile money facilite
tout ces transactions qui sont
impossibles dans un monde de banque
traditionnelle
parce que même pour consulter votre sol
dans une banque traditionnelle vous
devez payer
chez nous c'est juste un code du ssd et
vous avez le solde alors c'est la
facilité et la disponibilité qui a fait
le succès de mobile money aujourd'hui en
afrique est aussi largement en côte
d'ivoire mais le mobile money
d'aujourd'hui n'est qu'au début ce n'est
que le début
qu'est ce qui va se passer demain ou
est-ce que nous allons avec mme balme
onu dans le futur aujourd'hui nous avons
3 4 millions d'ivoiriens
qui utilise mobile monique sur une base
journalière
quelles sont leurs transactions qui font
ces deux-là transfert d'argent j'envoie
l'argent à mes parents qui sont rodier
neige envoie l'argent la nounou c'était
transfert d'argent au k2 physiquement
aller vers la personne ou le bus qui
part à la gare routière et qui va aller
déposer de l'autre côté ce sont des
mécanismes du passé aujourd'hui avec le
transfert d'argent
il ya beaucoup de transactions mobile
money qui se limite à une simple
transaction de transférer de l'argent
d'un point à un autre point une autre
application de base c'est acheter du
crédit téléphonique
bien sûr on fait la promotion de notre
propre produit alors on donne beaucoup
de incentive si vous voulez d'acheter
les retards mais ça c'est le début où
est ce que nous allons avec mobile money
dans les 5 10 ans à venir mobile money
va fondamentalement changé la façon que
nous allons vivre que nous allons
interagir que nous allons faire
participer à l'économie
le vrai enjeu de mobile money c'est le
développement de l'écosystème
le système au tour de toutes les
applications de mobile money je vous
donne un exemple c'est pas un rêve
aujourd'hui peut-être encore en rêvent
mais dans quelques années ça va être une
réalité
imaginons un employé solibra qui reçoit
solibra pour ceux qui sont pas des côte
d'ivoire c'est société de brasserie la
bière gocad tout ça je vais pas de la
publicité mais c'est juste un exemple
alors un employé de la solibra qui
reçoit une partie de son salaire en
mobile money il prend le taxi pour
rentrer à la maison et y pays
ces mille francs aux 2000 francs de
déplacement au taximan en mobile money
le taximan peut maintenant avec son
mobile money de l'argent qu'il a reçus
payer une vignette ou pas s'est payé un
passage au 3ème pont où il peut acheter
un pneu
j'ai le garage garagiste pour remplacer
sont plus que le garagiste maintenant
qui a reçu son argent au mobile money
son paiement mobile money il peut il
peut aller au maquis acheter une bière
n'est ce pas et quand il sera au maquis
et il va payer avec mon père money saint
pierre avait le gérant de l'huma qui va
acheter la bière de solibra avec le même
mobile money et c'est ça l'enjeu c'est
ça l'enjeu de mobile money dans les
années à venir c'est que l'argent
virtuel va circuler va tourner va
tourner va tourner et nous allons
arriver à un moment donné qu' à aucun
moment donné l'argent virtuel seront
encore en argent physique et ça
s'appellera le cash laisse society ça
veut dire une société sans argent
liquide mais uniquement avec de l'argent
virtuel de l'argent mobile et ce n'est
pas si loin
il ya encore deux ou trois jours j'ai lu
un article qui a des échos des grands
professeurs d'économie en europe qui ont
fait une recommandation aux banques
centrales
da terme d'interdire d'éliminer l'argent
physique nous en afrique on est déjà
dans cette phase dans quelques années il
y aura plus du billet il y aura plus de
pièces tout va se passer de façon
virtuelle avec mobile money pour
terminer et pour vous montrer à quel
point mon bel money aujourd'hui fait
déjà partie du quotidien de beaucoup de
gens je vous donne l'exemple
une petite anecdote qui est mat arrivé
personnellement en ouganda ouganda c'est
un pays d'afrique de l'est l'afrique de
l'est avec le kenya qui a été un des
pionniers
dans le mobile money alors je conduis je
suis en voiture et le policier m'arrête
contrôle de papiers bon élève
j'ai le permis j'ai l'assurance j'ai
tout ce qu'il me faut que je montre je
doute fort qu'ils très bien mais mon ami
policier dit mais il fait chaud mon ami
fait chaud tu es en règle c'est vrai
demande pour ton frère combien tu peux
pas faire quelque chose bon je cherches
tu vas une pièce ils voient que je suis
en train de chercher je suis de bonne
foi que je veux vraiment lui donner
quelque chose mais ils voient que je ne
trouve pas il me dit mon ami c'est pas
grave si tu n'as pas si tu n'as pas de
monnaie voici mon numéro de téléphone
alors
is africa challenging the world
yes we à 5